two weeks to go until the cop 26 u.n
climate summit in glasgow it's been
described as the world's last best hope
to limit global warming but there may be
a big problem looming
when we spoke to u.s special envoy on
climate change john kerry earlier this
month he commented on the stalling
progress of a bill that contains a
sweeping plan to decarbonize america's
electricity the sausage making is not
pretty
but in the end they're going to have a
sausage i believe
but that is now in doubt because of this
man senator joe manchin a democrat from
the coal reliant state of west virginia
who wields a decisive vote in the senate
he is refusing to support the clean
power plan and it may be withdrawn
suddenly the united states a global
leader in the fight against climate
change urging other nations to do more
looks like it can't follow its own
advice with potentially huge
consequences
it makes it more difficult for the us to
push china and other countries to do
more
towards net zero emission reduction
targets in mid-century if china and
those other countries can say
you've set a target but you're not
making progress towards implementing it
which they've already put out as a
defensive shield against the pressure on
them to do more
america's domestic political problems
are not the only issue the government's
cop 26 unit in westminster is having to
consider at the moment
it's emerged that some of the summit's
main corporate sponsors including skye
have previously written to the
government raising concerns about the
way it was being organized and activists
are complaining about ongoing problems
with the availability and cost of
accommodation which might prevent them
from attending
in a statement a cop 26 spokesperson
said we are committed to hosting an
inclusive summit in two weeks time which
showcases innovative work from a range
of businesses and civil society groups
who are committed to tackling climate
change together ministers are continuing
to focus their time on helping to secure
a positive outcome in glasgow
organizing an international summit is
not an easy task and at this crucial
moment as nearly 200 nations each with
individual needs and pressures prepare
to gather in glasgow delivering a
successful one will be even harder
hannah thomas peter sky news in
westminster